this morning as part of our series the
dish I am very proud to introduce you to
a man on a mission to bring a 100
authentic Taste of Mexico to the U.S his
name is Daria Willows he was born in the
U.S but raised in Monterey Mexico and
his goal is to introduce our taste buds
to real Mexican tacos while also
surrounding Us in his restaurants with
everything he loves about the culture of
where he grew up and the result is to
Comey right now a series of taquerias in
New York Miami and Washington D.C and
plans now to open dozens more from coast
to coast
it's nice to be back in here yeah it
feels okay there's a good reason this
old VW bus is parked in the middle of a
New York City restaurant so the tacos
would come over the top to people here
yep we'd press the tortillas right here
and then we'd put them on the griddle
the bus used to be the restaurant
right cut open the combi okay basically
cut the roof off it right so I could
peel it back so you could stand up
inside but so you cut it with what like
a metal saw or shears or what you know
those circular metal saws I just got on
top of the bus and just got right
through it so you only get one shot at
that you you do you get one shot
Dario woolos has turned that shot into a
gathering Empire of taquerias making
tacombe one of the fastest growing
restaurants in America all with a
mission of sharing Mexican food and
culture and it started when he was just
another 20-something working for an
internet startup looking for the
Comforts of home there was a Taqueria in
Boston I remember I would go to it and
it just it wasn't hitting that spot
then this company asked me to open up
the London office and and I go over
there and there was no Mexican food in
London I started talking about it a lot
with my friends one of them said Dario
you should you should start your
business here in Mexico he's like you
you don't know what you're doing you've
been talking about maybe opening it up
in London and it's better you lose all
your money here and I was like all right
the name to kombi is a mashup of the
words taco and Kobe meaning boss it
brought together these two things that
are common all over Mexico ubiquitous
every person in Mexico has at some point
ridden in a Combi you know VW box yeah
and and Tacos you know every street
corner city of Mexico has awesome tacos
with the office life behind him he
parked his first Combi outside a
nightclub in Playa del Carmen and went
travel to Mexico slowed in 2009 he moved
his bus to New York City I can take
credit for starting takombi but I can't
take credit for what it is today he now
has 15 restaurants open in five cities
and hopes to take to kombi to the rest
of America and the world there's just so
much positive intention that goes into
delivering a taco it's so simple but but
there's just so much behind it
as we learned when we stepped behind the
counter with Oscar Hernandez Dario's
first hire at Jacoby and now the
company's Master to Cairo this is like
uh one of the one of our most popular
tacos in tacombi Hernandez showed us the
tacombi version of the famous Baja Fish
Taco we use a Atlantic Coast it's a
flaky but it doesn't break when you fry
it
and then we also uh deep it in a beer
butter the batter is made from Mexican
beer and when it comes out of the fryer
it's a little Tangy spicy it's topped
with a sauce made from Mexican chilies
and to keep it crispy not salsa but
pickled veggies as part of my daily diet
yes
that's a perfect excretion so good when
people ask you like how's that taco you
say that that's it how do people screw
this up
something that I will definitely not
recommend is go to the supermarket and
pick up one of those bags that says
Mexican cheese blend and add it to this
Taco I mean they're definitely why why
what's wrong with the Mexican cheese bun
uh the Mexican cheese blend that I
normally find on supermarkets I don't
know what part of Mexico is that coming
from how much experimentation went into
this as I take the last delicious bite
there's been many many thousands of
tries at this one of the things that
we've learned over the years is how
important the tortilla is
so important in fact that when he
couldn't find the quality of tortilla he
was looking for in New York
he started making his own so no one's
ever called you the Willy Wonka of corn
not yet you're the first inside a shiny
new Factory along the Brooklyn
Waterfront he showed us the process of
turning bags of corn
into bags of corn tortillas we're making
150 000 tortillas a day 150 000. yeah
and you can see when they come out some
of them see how they they fluff yeah
right and that's what makes a really
good tortilla you know what I Love
Actually there's like little
imperfections but everyone's a little
different just like if you're making it
in a home kitchen totally pick your pick
your tortilla I love it so
oh a lot of people in Mexico when you
get tortillas on the table Yeah you roll
it up and you'll dip it in your soup you
kind of like the way uh Americans eat
bread right his Vista Hermosa chips and
tortillas now ship out to Grocery stores
nationwide and Shake Shack founder Danny
Meyer has invested millions in a plan to
eventually build tacombe restaurants all
across America but Willow says success
for him is defined by more than just
sales you've been doing this for how
many years now takombi overall overall
17 years now it came from a place of
love you still love it yeah totally
totally it takes me back to Growing Up
in Mexico go it takes me to back to
where I started to Combi when I when I
was in Playa del Carmen I used to go buy
my tortillas at a local Tortilleria and
you know you step into these tortillas
and just like we did now you have that
smell yeah the fresh corn being ground
and then cooked it's it's pretty special
so you're thousands of miles away from
home but in another way closer than ever
yes that's pretty cool
dude I don't know I can smell it coming
through the screen I told you I'm going
home today stopping by at Tacoma you
should stop by Tacoma because you know
someone might say oh you know he's
trying to sell his product of course
he's going to say it's authentic well
here is a fact check on that uh so Daisy
Perez who helped put this piece together
uh someone on my team her mother is from
Mexico Daisy correct me if I'm wrong on
this we brought home the tortillas she
smelled them said it brought her back to
Childhood and ate the entire bag made
Daisy nothing oh didn't cook a thing for
her
yeah so there's a commitment to
authenticity and it is real so good and
it's it's tasty dig in
so the chips are actually made from the
fried tortillas okay okay they're not
cut separately into little triangles
they're made into circles and then they
become triangles and another point on
the authenticity this is hilarious so
initially he was so committed to it that
he was like we're not selling guacamole
they don't do that in Mexico and the
taquerias don't have guacamole or
they're gonna be authentic and basically
Americans revolted they were like
everybody who came in was like I want
the guac I want the guac they sell the
salsa as well uh I don't know they don't
sell salsa would you get this in the
grocery store Whole Foods uh I went home
there's one at my place on the upper
west side just opened about a year ago
it is awesome bottom line at this point
uh there's one coming to just about
every point it's coming to your neck
soon chips